couple of months ago i was asked to
participate in a debate
organized by ibm and bloomberg news
and the discussion centered on the
question
is the space race between the us and
china good for humanity
oh interesting and all the other
debaters
were worried about the military threats
yeah
and i just couldn't understand what
they're talking about because
military threats come from hovering
above the surface of the earth right
and we live on a two-dimensional surface
we live on the surface of the earth but
space is all about the third dimension
getting far from error
so if you go to mars or you go to a star
another star
there is no military threat what are we
talking about
space is all about you know feeling that
you know we are one civilization in fact
not fighting each other
just going far and having aspirations
for something that goes beyond military
threats yeah
so why would we be worried that the
space race will lead
that's actually brilliant i didn't you
know there's some it does
in our discourse about it the space race
is sometimes
made synonymous with like the cold war
or something like that right or with
wars but
really yeah there was a lot of ego tied
up in that i remember i mean it's still
still to this day there's a lot of pride
that russians the soviet union was the
first of space and there's a lot of
pride in the american side that
was the first on the moon but yeah
you're exactly right like there's no
aggression
there's no wars and and beyond that if
you think about the global economy
right now uh there is a commercial
interest that's why jeff bezos
and elon musk are interested about you
know mars and so forth
there is a commercial interest which is
international it's not it's driven by
money
yes not by name by pride and
you know nations can sign treaties first
of all
there are lots of trees that were signed
even before the first world war and the
second world war and the world war took
place so
who cares you know like humans treaties
do not
safeguard anything you know but beyond
that
even if nations sign treaties about
space exploration
you might still find commercial entities
that will
find a way to get their launches and you
know so
i think we should rethink space it has
nothing to do with national pride
once again nothing to do with our egos
it's about
exploration
you